[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo los saludas debilidad riaño
[Música]
una de las herramientas usadas por los
estados para garantizar la ayuda a
quienes huyen de sus países por crisis
humanitarias son los estatutos de
protección éstos complementan el régimen
de protección internacional de
refugiados y buscan una respuesta
nacional a las necesidades de los
expatriados colombia es un ejemplo en
américa latina' hace un año el gobierno
anunció el estatuto temporal de
protección que facilita el acceso a
derechos a la población venezolana
veamos cómo va su implementación en el
informe de luís muñoz
el estatuto de protección temporal para
los migrantes venezolanos en colombia ha
cumplido un año en este contexto el país
ha estado realizando jornadas de
regularización masivas como esta en
bogotá a la que han acudido unos 60.000
venezolanos en las últimas semanas y
estamos contentos por el nuevo permiso
son diez años que
que vamos a estar como regular ya no
vamos a estar irregularmente
aquí en el país y vamos a estar muy muy
contento con todo esto que están
haciendo con nosotros el estatuto
permite durante diez años acceso a la
salud y educación al mercado laboral ya
prestaciones sociales yo me siento muy
feliz y agradecida con con este país
colombia pues que me ha dado la
oportunidad de obtener este permiso que
de verdad me sirve para mucho primero
para la salud que es lo importante
porque mientras tengamos salud o podemos
trabajar honradamente se trata de una
medida pionera del gobierno de iván
duque que está siendo referente para
otros países de américa latina con el
visto bueno de las naciones unidas este
fue el mensaje de eduardo este en
representante especial conjunto de acnur
y la organización internacional para las
migraciones para los refugiados
inmigrantes de venezuela este gran
esfuerzo de inclusión ha enviado también
un importante mensaje contra la
discriminación como política y programa
que fomenta la cohesión es fundamental
para reducir las percepciones erróneas
haciendo frente a la estigmatización y a
la xenofobia
colombia haya entregado el estatuto
temporal de protección a cerca de
300.000 personas mientras acoge a 18
millones de refugiados inmigrantes de
los cerca de 5 millones que hay en toda
américa latina es el país que más
venezolanos ha recibido y desde la
regularización pretende marcar ejemplo
para uno de los grandes retos
internacionales de presente y futuro la
migración y otro de los países que
trabaja en acuerdos de estancia para los
extranjeros con necesidades de
protección es israel los solicitantes de
asilo sudaneses cuentan con un estatus
de residencia temporal ahora la puerta
está abierta para que accedan a
beneficios que antes no podían esta es
la historia
savona mohamed hassan huyó de la
violencia en darfur sudán cuando tenía
sólo 8 años lejos de su familia tuvo que
atravesar egipto y el desierto del sinaí
para llegar a israel los inicios como
migrantes fueron duros bajad latente y
no tenía nada para comer no tenía nada
los dos primeros meses para dormir aquí
fueron una locura me dice que estoy
haciendo aquí fue un momento tan loco
cuando entré israel
ahora con 26 años y después de una vida
de trabajos esporádicos a sanz ha sido
uno de los
2.440 solicitantes de asilo sudaneses a
los que se les ha concedido el estatus
de residencia temporal lo primero que
hará será ir a visitar a su madre a
visitar a mi mamá esa es la clave en
hace 18 años que no la veo llevo desde
los 8 años sin ver a mis familiares ha
sido horrible esperar este momento
espero verles tauro my friend the
members
la regularización para los sudaneses de
darfur nilo azul y las montañas de nuba
estará vigente hasta que se tome una
decisión sobre sus solicitudes de asilo
con el estatuto pueden ser dueños de un
negocio conducir obtener atención médica
y seguridad social y viajar al
extranjero se trata de una resolución de
la corte suprema que obligó a poner fin
a unas demoras que dejaban a los
migrantes en una nube de incertidumbre
changes la orden de la corte supone un
cambio y viene decir su gobierno tiene
una obligación bajo el derecho
internacional y bajo la ley israelí y si
no lo cumple entonces nosotros la corte
le daremos estos derechos mientras
ustedes deciden hacer su trabajo
en 2003 en darfur los rebeldes tomaron
las armas contra el gobierno de sudán
jartúm aplastó la revuelta en una ola de
violencia que desde eeuu se ha
calificado de genocidio
acnur reporta 41 mil 538 solicitantes de
asilo refugiados y otras poblaciones de
interés en israel de los cuales 6 mil 63
son
los estatutos de protección temporal
hacen parte de los esfuerzos de los
países de acogida por la inclusión de
los migrantes y solicitantes de asilo y
son además parte de la búsqueda de
soluciones y la regularización ante el
flujo de personas a una nación como es
el caso de los venezolanos en colombia y
el dato de inmigración de la semana
ah
14 refugiados de américa latina y el
caribe comparten recetas fusión en un
libro en el que mezclan sabores de su
país y de la nación que ahora los acoge
son 14 platos llenos de historias que
usted puede descargar a través de la
página web de acnur la invitación es a
cocinar con los refugiados
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]